[Music]
love was in the air at the 90th annual
Academy Awards some of Hollywood's
biggest stars turned Oscar night into
date night packing on the PDA at the
Dolby theater and all the parties across
town Kelly Ripa puckered up for a steamy
smooch with her husband Mark Consuelos
while first-time Oscar winner Kobe
Bryant flashed a smile with his gorgeous
wife Vanessa by his side
Kobe how does this feel tonight Mark
Hamill and his wife Mary Lou York gave
off a sillier vibe striking a series of
epic poses meanwhile at the Vanity Fair
party Sofia Vergara and Joe Manganiello
posed it up Jason Sudeikis and Olivia
Wilde's were all smiles new mama mindy
kaling and her ex DJ novak worked it for
the cameras Sarah Paulson & Holland
Taylor walked the carpet arm-in-arm and
Megan Mullally and Nick Offerman brought
the laughs Miley Cyrus and Liam
Hemsworth looked perfectly chic as they
cozied up at Elton John's bash and get
this that's rumored flames Tom Holland
and zendaya making their way into the
Governor's Ball